[Music]
hello and welcome to a very last minute
live video for sidetrek your sci-fi tv
and movie channel um
me and my resident american matey over
here stormy bear we're just talking on
another channel uh the machine channel
the machine
and i just happened to mention i was
going to make this video and stormy
actually has
proper insight into this
so we thought we would just do this
video really really fast so
pro remake is going to happen the crow
movie um back with obviously brandon lee
1993
um is going to be a complete hard reboot
apparently
um it's going to be directed by rupert
sander who did snow white and huntsman a
film i actually quite like and ghost in
the shell a film i didn't like
um and we'll starring bill skarsgard the
guy that played pennywise in the it's
sequels is going to be playing the crow
um
i just happened to mention to you stormy
that i i really don't like that this
film is getting
um a lot of
attention at the moment because the
cynic in me
i think it's because that the crow is a
great movie that's right for a reboot
the cynic in me thinks that this is
getting attention right now because
everything happened on the rust movie
um everything that happened with um
i'm sorry i've written a name down uh
sorry alec baldwin accidentally shooting
helene hutchins
um in a very similar way
um in lots of ways to what happened to
brandon lee and during the 1993 movie
um
first of all just tell us a little bit
about why you have a personal connection
to
this movie and why it's important to
what we're talking about uh
in the late 80s early 90s i used to have
a special
prop effect shop here in north carolina
and mostly i was working out of
wilmington
i was doing you know any kind of
specialized prop that had to be
custom-made whether out of metal or
wood or whatever i would make
if you look up storm bear on imdb i'm in
there someplace making really cheap
movies man
good on you so
i was trying to get the contract for the
miniatures
for uh the crow i think the producer was
richard pressman and that was one stingy
son of a [ __ ] he just
didn't want to spend money on anything i
don't i really don't know who the model
makers are or were that actually got the
contract but i was giving it my good old
college try
and you know
at that point in time wilmington or
wilmy wood north carolina was um
everybody knew everybody you know we'd
all worked on other things together you
know it was a small tight-knit community
you know
you know and even you know prop makers
like myself we'd rub elbows with
celebrities
and it was
it was just nothing it was like well
this is my bud right
so
i'd met brandon in late
brandon lee uh in late 1992
or early 93. one thing i think is like
right before christmas somehow
and we used to play pool in this little
place look so pool hall and wrightsville
beach where you know is just
is just a seaside pool hall
and uh i didn't get to work on the film
uh and i was gutted
when i found out that uh brandon had
been shot
and killed
on the on the sack
and you know james obar the the guy that
uh wrote the original graphic novel the
crow he sent me a nice autographed copy
you know with an inscription you know i
miss brandon too
and it was the people that were making
the film and and just in wilmington
in the film community of wilmington
north carolina we were just
flabbergasted that this could possibly
happen
and
there's a scene in the movie where
they're playing poker and they're i
think they're swap there's these bullets
on the table or whatever and they're
flipping them up and they're swallowing
or whatever and then all of a sudden
they have to go there's something they
have to rush off and do
my theater my
theory is that
when they when the whoever the was
responsible for the guns
put one of those
in
back into the gun
right
well the thing is those weren't real
loads those were not loaded they were
just you know
props
but the slug
in the in in the brass that it just fell
out and stuck in the barrel
you know usually when you're on pr on
set and you go through and you check a
gun you stare down the barrel with a
light on the other and make sure there's
no obstruction
and so no one did that and so the the
the slug was still in the gun
and so for another c or another scene
specifically the one where they killed
uh brandon lee they put the blank round
in which is mostly all just powder
gunpowder
and then when the actor pointed it at
lee and pulled the trigger
it hit him
and there was the actual slug comes
stumbling out of the barrel at high
velocity and got him right in the chest
that was the thing is that there was
never really a clear explanation
you see you said that's your theory and
there's a few one was just like a piece
of
something shrapnel or something was in
the barrel it wasn't clean properly and
i've seen these
these um
blank crowns
um they've got names that i watched the
documentary about how they've got three
or four different types around aren't
they
um that they use but a lot of these are
real guns i don't even know why on earth
they would have any sort of reason to
have real ammunition on a film set but
apparently they do
um as in some some circumstances in
westerns and things
um
it makes absolutely no sense to me that
these weapons would be capable of firing
around
but they want the nice to come at the
end don't they and to you know
when we're using or when they're using
um black fire rails there's a very large
cap thing that goes on the end
to prevent anything from coming at the
end of that barrel
um it diffuses the energy and it's but
it prevents any of these sorts of
accidents
it it it it
crazes my mind
that this sort of accident could ever
happen but it's happened twice how do
you feel though about the crow remo
reboot now happening because it's going
to be
apparently a complete remake a reboot
and i don't mean about them making the
film again i have no major problem that
they've been trying this is a film
they're trying to make
for about 15 years
um seriously trying to make
now it seems to be pushing forwards
the cynic in me says it's because
of what happened in the rust movie and
because public interest is in that at
the moment
how actually having a personal
connection to this how does that make
you feel
well you know i didn't you know when
they made sequels to the crow continuing
the story of the crow and draven you
know uh eric draven character i really
didn't have a problem with even when
that turned into a tv a short-lived tv
series you know
i mean it was a continuation story the
guy they got playing that was great that
dakakis guy he was a
really good character he was good he was
good you know and i think he you know
was really honorific
to
the legacy of
brandon lee in that role i mean
lee man i mean he did such a good job i
mean he was destined for huge things
that really was his breakout performance
and it was just
god but so anyway it's
you know why there was a bullet on this
a live round
on the set of rust is just beyond me i
mean it for for you know on the crow it
was
just negligence there wasn't any live
round there was you know i think you
know some sort of round from the that
scene in our old playing cards
fired up and
something lodged in the barrel
of the gun and no one checked it so when
they put
the overpowered you know uh
blank in there and then shot it whatever
was stuck was propelled out
and killed
brandon lee so in the
what they're doing now maybe they're
trying to
[Music]
make a point or maybe you know a drift
off of the back of the tragedy of rust
or
maybe they're trying
here's my theory they're trying to drift
all of the off of all the gun massacres
in america that's going on i mean i i'm
more cynical than you about it i think
you know it's every other week
you know
new york and then southern california at
the church and now in texas i mean
you know what's going to happen memorial
day you know i mean here in america it's
just like well you know we give enough
thoughts and prayers we forget about it
oh there's another shooting let's give
out some more thoughts and prayers
i'm i'm more cynical thinking that well
they're just trying to draft off of the
interest of guns
and massacres
to try to give it another shot because
you know
in the original
crow universe
you know detroit was lit was owned
by gangs
and gang violent the police had no
control you know it was just like
if you look at dc's the joker joke the
joker would be like just some
inconsequential bad guy compared to what
was going on in detroit in obara's
original graphic novels i mean it was
just out of control
the truth at one stage in detroit that
wasn't yeah yeah yeah yeah seriously
violent city
it just
it just feels to me that that it's just
such bad timing
and in bad taste
because
it does come off the back of what
happened with rust and that's not even
been concluded yet you know we've not
had the the full investigation and
you know we we still don't know really
how it happened
even though we got a good we got a good
obviously a good idea
um
they're going to be filming this movie
very shortly it's been greenlit they've
got the money
it just seems to me that
the timing
is coming off the back of the rust
incident coming off the back of another
shooting in america
that it's just
in bad taste
that they're only the only reason that
somebody has signed off a check and
actually gone yeah let's do this is
because they know people are talking
about it
and they're not talking about it because
of anything good they're not talking
about because they're talking about it
because it's happened again
so they're you know they're getting to
make a movie basically off the back of a
tragedy
and you know that one of the reasons why
this film has not been remade and one of
the reasons why the series didn't was
reasonably short-lived was because a lot
of fans of the original a lot of brandon
lee fans said this is disgusting what
are you doing how dare you make a movie
off
this incident off of what happens you
know and it's like
but they do that's what they're doing
that's how it feels to me i just think
and i'm completely with you brandon lee
made some horrible movies before he made
he got to make this film
um
and you know and now he he he made this
great movie it was not just great acting
great special effect great you know it
was just such a beautifully made movie
and even with um the way they had to cut
in the end to put a film that was
coherent together
um
it's just it just it just maxes me is
i mean like i said maybe i'm being
cynical but it just maxes me they've
only got the funding to go ahead with
this because of what happened on the
rust movie and that isn't right
it doesn't crosses
brandon couldn't believe his luck i mean
we were he just said how the hell did i
get this part this is awesome you know
and you know in the late 80s early 90s
was just the kind of the beginning of
movie studios taking superhero
movies seriously or graphic novels
movies seriously
you know and
he was just really enthused really
excited you know he
he was just
doing all sorts of things to be get into
character to understand who eric drake
was
and uh he was
just re felt really blessed to have this
opportunity and it killed him sounds
like a really humble guy
oh my god why he was a great dude yeah
he was just a really honest to god nice
guy
yeah you know not pretentious at
all yeah i think he dreamed about his
things losing his dad in such a young
age and things yeah you know being
brought up but being a lee
being bruce lee's son you know you can
imagine he probably took a lot of [ __ ]
as well growing up
well i don't know i think
man that guy was built i mean it was
just
brandon lee was just like he was one a
gym rat i mean he was just
i mean he wasn't schwarzenegger big but
he was really really fit
yeah yeah and i know he was a good man
he was a
you know a decent martial artist from
what i don't know if he was the same
thing
yeah oh yeah i've heard but you know you
hear stories about
people just walking up to bruce lee and
just offering him out for a fight
because of the
mythology of bruce lee i do i always
wondered how much of that rubbed off on
brandon whether he actually did
have to deal with some of that nonsense
um but he never put himself forward as a
martial artist necessarily did he was um
when when we were out and about
no one knew who the hell he was
good
he it was just
he was just some dude he could have been
you know somebody just going to the
beach for the week
no one knew who he was
you wouldn't have been able to do that
after the crow if that no he wouldn't i
mean yeah just he was totally he lived
in enemies anonymity
until the crow came out and then
everyone knew who he was then yeah but
it was he never had to suffer i mean he
no it was just we were two blokes in a
bar
playing pool every once in a while you
know or just staying in the bar part
he really didn't drink that much though
no i imagine him because he like said
he looks after himself so yeah yeah i
guess i drank for him but no he was a
really humble guy you know it was just
not flashy clothes just
i mean you could tell he could beat the
hell out of you
you know but he never would i mean it
was just
really thick
um
he did a film with dolph lundgren which
was the worst movie i've ever seen and
uh he goes he's got a one line in the
movie he he basically starts dolph lungs
and what how much of a big will he's got
and i guess i must that must have just
paid him so much money to do that but he
obviously he had to pay his dues didn't
he i got every actor at some point has
to pay your dues you know and and he did
you know he did pay his dues in some
really bad movies
and but then he just he got to make this
beautiful thing and i just i think it's
definitely one of those films it doesn't
need to be remade
um and it definitely shouldn't be remade
in the circumstances it's getting remade
for me
um
now if rust incident hadn't happened
right
possibly not
is
is the
james abbar the guy that came up with
the idea that the original artist behind
the uh
graphic novel has he come out and said
anything about
uh not as far as i know but he has
talked about the the movie being remade
in the past and it's something that he
said that that he would love um a remake
to be done but he wanted a sequel
he wanted something that honored the
original and at the moment it looks like
this is going to be a hard reboot so
it's going to be a completely retelling
um i would like to see something more
from his um wife's perspective maybe
um you know and and sort of a run-up to
the to to what happened to the movie and
which is something more i think they did
in the series and vaguely remember the
series
um
but there are other ways to tell this
story and that obviously there's a
graphic novel series
there are other stories to tell they
don't need to do
a hard reboot
i think that there are ways they could
do it and honor the original story
i'm with you that i wouldn't mind that i
just i do i don't like the timing
i just don't i think it's awful timing
um
we're coming up on the 30th anniversary
of the premiere that of the crow
here in a year
yeah 93 at 94 i think when it came out i
mean there's so much you know you could
you know it could um
yeah there's so many sequel ideas you
really don't have to remake the original
because i think we've all seen the
original it's like it's a long film or
anything
but i do understand you know hollywood's
just
knee-jerk reaction to remake the [ __ ]
out of everything because they have no
real ideas
left
but i know
obar had enough
material to make all sorts of films you
know off of just that one character
and um
i don't know
you know it's kind of personal for me
you know i know i'm the grumpy old man
here and i just don't see i would i'd
like to see new crow content i you know
i say that with every
you know thing that's gets rebooted
you know uh i knew remember i was kind
of stoic when battlestar galactica got
rebooted
you know but you know i got new content
i was really pleasantly surprised but
i don't know man it is i do find the
timing suspicious
you know especially in light of all the
recent shootings but you know if if
you're making this
you know and you're trying to to
make it without any uh mass shootings in
america well good luck you know because
there's always going to be a mass
shooting around the corner
and i so i think that at least for me
that's kind of an unfair
um
analogies oh we're playing office mass
shooting well dude you've been making
you've been writing it for a year you've
been making it for a year
how many mass shootings has there been
i mean you can't find a place to market
it or make it or it's not going to be
during a mass shooting or right
afterwards and i guarantee you whatever
day they pick to
to premiere this there will be some sort
of mass shooting
around that time
and before then there'll be one after
and everyone will blame the crow the
remake for all this violence and it's
just
blame mental health it's not a good
problem it's a mental health problem god
trump's energy
all right okay
yeah well i'm saying it's just really
amazing that you've got this personal
link to
what i consider to be one of the the
the sadder losses i i i think like
heath ledger
doing that that part in the wrong and
you know the joker in batman and we were
just gonna ask you know stratospheric
and we lost him i think brandon lee
you know obviously it's much worse for
his friends and his family people that
knew him like you knew him you know as
much as was that but from a movie lover
i just feel like you know the amount of
what we missed out on it may be a very
selfish way but what we missed out on
the art he could have created and
probably
almost certainly would have created did
create in the crow
um and what what he could have done um
it's just
sad and i just hope
they don't
trample on that memory
when they make this movie but maybe i'm
being too cynical
it's hollywood man you have to be
cynical
yeah true
thank you so much for joining me very
very quickly
um
and again uh just just
every time you tell me a different story
about you just something you mentioned
that going on i met brandon lee what
that's just amazing uh such an
interesting i mean carl sagan too i just
didn't know it at the time
yes and bloody um chris pine as well and
you didn't know it was christmas i was
such an idiot i really was i was such an
idiot i met captain kirk and didn't
notice you such a tit
so
i never watch spoilers i never read
spoilers you know i would i ignore your
channel because i don't want to know
what's going to happen you know
well i try to i always try to ignore
everything so i can enjoy it in the
theater or whatever
and uh i went to go see this um
wasn't bottle shock what the hell was it
was a bottle shot no it was a bottle
shock
oh hell i can't remember the name of the
movie let me let me go look it up it was
it was chris pine was
was in this movie before
about napa valley right and i was living
in san francisco at a time so it's kind
of like
everybody you know oh let's it says
let's it's a movie about wine let's go
watch it
no it was bottle shock yeah yeah yeah bo
he played a bo barrett it was kind of a
concerning the historical uh kind of
historical uh story
about uh
how california wine
um went up against french wine and won
in a contest
and you know it was
i i was it was showing at
the san francisco cinema society was
showing this at
the kabuki theater in japan town
and i went to go see it you know all the
really hardcore old rich film nerds went
there i you know bought my ticket and
just went in so we got to talk with the
cast that nobody i had no clue i mean i
knew
his name was chris pine but i you know
because i've shunned everything star
trek i had not a damn clue
about it we were more you know i i think
i asked him so
are you a white wine or red wine kind of
guy and i can't remember what he said
that was it that was just
we could have got an insight into what
captain cook drinks
no not me
yeah
[Music]
right well
thank you so much
again
i haven't watched silverspeed go watch
the crow it's a beautiful movie you
really will
um
these i think they seem to be marking a
low life in light enough uh late in life
stories like clearly even forgiving
amazon's recent night sky so it comes to
mind there just seems to be a market for
that sort of thing at the moment night
sky was amazing
i still haven't watched it but i'm going
to i'm just watching the um stranger
things and i'm watching night sky i've
talked my wife into it so again stormy
thank you so much for joining bringing
us your personal take on this story um
reboot will be filmed this year it will
be out next year
um
let's just enjoy it as a movie and maybe
not worry too much about
the reasons why it got made fingers
crossed it'll be a word and probably the
time it gets made and gets out no one
will remember rust
exactly
well yeah i hope
anyway
thanks again guys as always please stay
safe stormy thank you so much for
watching you'll be good
oh if you can't be good be careful
see you later see ya bye
[Music]